so I like to make sure that I show the good
bad and ugly of state of motherhood and motherhood in general on my page
and today is a really hard fucking day
and I just wanna talk about a little bit
because I know I'm not the only person who feels this way
I feel like I'm failing at everything
that I'm stretched so thin that I'm not accomplishing anything super well
I feel like I'm being dragged behind semi truck that's going 100 miles per hour
but there's no one at the wheel
and I'm just holding onto a rope at the back of it and just
it's not getting away from me
but I'm definitely not in the driver's seat
and I think I potentially stretched myself so thin trying to be good
and on top of everything that I'm on top of absolutely nothing
and I logically know the part of this is
because we just got done with my daughter's birthday
it was a lot of work it was a lot of effort
it was like two days of not good sleep
and I'm starting Monday kind of behind the aimball because of it
but I feel completely drained
I feel completely drained
and I've so much to do and I feel paralyzed that I can't do anything
because I'm gonna choose the wrong thing to focus on
and then everything else won't get done
that actually might be my add
I've also been out of my meds for days because they had supply issues
so instead of being on my adderall and like
being able to think clearly
I've been raw dogging this entire fucking weekend with extra shit to do
and it is not going well my friends
and today it just seems all so fucking impossible
cooking and taking down Halloween
and cleaning and doing laundry and getting everybody ready for cold weather
and homeschooling the kids and making sure that they're learning cursive
because all their friends in school are learning cursive
even though I think it's fucking stupid
and they're not gonna need cursive
usually I talk to my husband about all this
but he's losing his shit too
because we are just trying to figure out the next chapter of our life
and he is working so hard
and he is burned out so we can't be lifting each other up
because we're both dragging ourselves behind the semi truck
and on top of everything
I'm finally at a point where I think I just feel numb about the election
and my fears for what's going forward
I'm watching Donald Trump pick a cabinet that looks more like some sort of
like super villain Batcave of egotistical piece of shit men
um and I
I just oh
my god happy Thanksgiving
I need a vacation
and maybe a coma but like
a small one just enough to feel really well rested